[Music]
Hello friends this is Doug Bachelor how
about an amazing fact in the summer of
1945 engineer Percy Spencer was
conducting tests on a magnetron that's
the powerful tube at the heart of every
radar set when he reached into his
pocket for a chocolate bar he found it
had melted he wondered if the magnetron
could be responsible curious to see what
was going on he put a bag of corn
kernels in front of the magnetron voila
the first batch of microwave popcorn
Spencer patented the new method of
cooking his employer rathon company
transformed his Discovery into the first
microwave and called it a radar range
the first model was 6 feet tall weighed
750 lb and had a price tag of
$33,000 early sales were obviously slow
gradually the size and the price of
microwaves became more manageable so
today they're considered an
indispensable kitchen appliance every
year microwaves save people thousands of
hours normally spent watching a stove
incredibly Percy Spencer was also the
engineering genius who had already
helped America win World War II by
devising a method to mass-produce radar
sets you might be interested to know
this engineering genius with more than
300 patents had only a third grade
education dauntless he taught himself
trigonometry calculus chemistry physics
and Metallurgy among other subjects the
Bible says God has done some great
things through ordinary people that are
hungry for truth stay with us friends
we're going to learn more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of Bible
answers
live welcome to Bible answers live with
author and evangelist Pastor Doug
Bachelor is Understanding God's word a
challenge are there passages of
scripture that are a mystery to you
maybe it's difficult to reconcile what
you've read in the Bible to what you've
always
believed if you have Bible related
questions stay tuned to get honest
practical answers straight from the word
of God on Bible answers live Bible
answers live is a production of amazing
facts Ministries dedicated to spreading
the Gospel of Jesus Christ to the entire
world our lines are open so call us now
at 800 God says that's 800
46372 N7
now here's your host Pastor Doug
Bachelor welcome listening friends to
Bible answers live and this is the
program if you've got a Bible question
lines are open pick up your phone give
us a call here's the number 800 God says
that's 800
46372 97 lines open you call now really
good chance you're going to get your
question on tonight's broadcast proof to
us out there you're listening give us a
call with your Bible question 800 God
says 8800
46372 N7 will bring your question into
our studio and this is live my name is
Doug Bachelor my name is Jean Ross good
evening listening friends and Pastor
Doug let's begin the program with the
word of prayer dear father once again we
are grateful that we have this time to
spend a few moments in your word and as
we open up the Bible we ask for the Holy
Spirit to come and guide our hearts and
and lead us Lord into a clearer full
understanding of your will as revealed
in scripture be with those who are
listening wherever they might be Lord
and together may we discover a fuller
understanding of your will for our lives
I thank you for promising to be with us
in jesus' name amen amen well Pastor D
open the program by talking about a
remarkable individual who uh was able to
take I guess some rather complicated
technology and um number one make it
readily available to a lot of people but
then come up with probably one of the
greatest discoveries when it comes to
cooking and saving time of course theone
microwave yep Percy Spencer was an
amazing man in that he is born very poor
he didn't even know about electricity
until he was about nine he this lived in
a rural area of Maine and uh lost his
mother and his father fairly young then
his uncle that was raising him uh
abandon him and he had to drop out of
school to help support his aunt after
third grade but when he entered the Navy
uh he was fascinated by uh
radio and um he studied it until he
basically became their expert and then
when radar was discovered and that was
so crucial in the winning of World War
II he's the one that developed a way to
make it small enough to mass produce it
and then towards the end of the war then
he was working for the rathon company
and he that you know I always worried if
if the chocolate bar was melting in his
pocket how many times was his body
exposed to microwaves it's amazing he
didn't cook himself right but um he's
lived to 75 so I guess it didn't hurtt
him too much but you know it reminds me
of the examples we see in the Bible of
how God takes people with fairly common
ordinary humble beginnings and does
remarkable things through them I mean
you think of Jesus for one thing is when
when they heard about Jesus talking you
know he was born poor he grew up uh you
know in a Carpenters shop and yet they
were amazed at his knowledge and
learning you can read in John 7:15
and the Jews marveled saying how does
this man know letters having never
studied I mean where did he get this
incredible sophisticated
education and then his followers the
disciples you can read in Acts 4:13 when
they were standing trial before the
Jewish Supreme Court it says when they
saw the boldness of Peter and John and
they perceived they were uneducated and
untrained men they marveled and they
realized they had been with Jesus you
see the Holy Spirit can teach you more
more in 5 minutes than all of the
institutions of Higher Learning in a
lifetime that's not that we're against
education but if you really want to
learn the fear of the Lord is the
beginning of wisdom and even Paul when
he was writing to the early church he
said for you see and this is by the way
1 Corinthians
1:26 he said you see your calling
Brethren how not many wise after the
flesh not many mighty not many noble are
called but God has chosen the fool
things of the world to confound the wise
God has chosen the weak things of the
world to confound the things that are
Mighty and the base things of the world
and the things that are despised has God
chosen yay and things which are not to
bring to not things that are that no
flesh should glory in his presence you
know if a person has a hunger for truth
and for knowledge the bible promises if
we hunger and thirst after
righteousness then we'll be filled and
then Jesus made that other promise he
says if you're willing to do his will
you will know of the doctrine so God
reveals truth to those that are willing
to do truth and there may be some people
out there that are thinking you know I'd
like to know the truth we have a book
that will tell you how to guard
against being self- deceived and not
knowing truth and why don't you tell us
about that Pastor Ross the book this
evening our free offer is called hidden
eyes and closed ears and it's dealing
with how do we respond to Truth uh there
are many who don't want to hear truth
less they need to make a change in their
life but the Bible always encourages us
follow truth pursue wisdom as the wise
man says knowledge of God knowledge of
the truth we'll be happy to send this
book to anybody who calls and asks for
it the number to call is
6747 you can ask for the book called
hidden eyes and closed ears again hidden
eyes and closed ears that's the name of
the book and the number to call our
resource line is 800 835
6747 and if you're listening to this on
the internet and you happen to be
outside North America you're unable to
call at take heart just go to the
Amazing Facts website amazing facts.org
and you can type in there hidden eyes
closed ears and you can read the pdf
version of the book for free online just
amazing facts.org all right we've got uh
couple questions why don't we get
started all right our first caller this
evening is Aon listening in car Michael
Aaron welcome to the program hi um good
evening I had a question about Acts
chapter 29 I mean excuse me acts
17 uh chapter 17 verse 29 where it talks
about um it says therefore and I'm
reading out n therefore since we are
God's Offspring we should not think that
the Divine being is like uh gold or
silver Stone image made by man's design
and skill well I've been sort of with
that first part I know he's talking to
the Athens Paul and I just don't really
understand that first part of God's
Offspring okay uh well and you find it
it's starts I guess in verse um well
yeah verse 28 for in him we live and
move and have our being as certain of
your own poet so said now Paul's
referring to some of the Athenian poets
for we are also his offspring meaning
Offspring means the children and again
it repeats in verse 29 for as much then
as we are The Offspring of God we ought
not think that the godhead is like gold
or silver or stone in other words when
we see that we're made in the image of
God and we see we're not Stone and we're
not gold and we're not you know made out
of these wood ID idle materials God is a
living moving real being since we're his
children so why do we fashion god to
look like beasts and these different
creatures that uh you know in Greece
they had statues of I forget what the
word is for these things that are half
human like half goat they've got a word
for that but anyway they had all kinds
of very strange concepts of what God was
like and you can look for instance in 1
John 3 verse one it says behold what
manner of love the father has bestowed
on us that we should be called the
children of God we are the sons of God
and so we're adopted into the family and
that's why it says you know if we're
born again we are his offspring we're
the children of God so that's in essence
what I think Paul is talking to he he
Paul is very clever he saw that the um
Athenians had this prominade that had
idols and gods dedications on his right
and left and as he came upon one he saw
that there was a pillar there with a
plaque and it said to the unknown God
just in case we missed one we made a
plaque to we don't want to miss any God
so we're honoring the unknown God Paul
said let me tell you about that God and
so he used it as a great opportunity to
talk to him about Jehovah and uh tell
him the truth but um does that make
sense Aon yeah that that makes sense I
just had somebody trying to like say
like so we're like like God and I said
well but that's different with Lucifer
and stuff and it it it was someone with
another belief system that I think was
trying to twist trying to do twist
trying to make people sound like they're
Divine or something huh yeah they like
they can become Divine which you know I
know isn't true but I was like that let
me do some research into that I'll get
back to you so all right yeah I
appreciate it you know also if you look
at the genealogy of um mankind it goes
back and it talks about the various
descendants and follow that all the way
back through Genesis and talks about
Adam and it says Adam the Son of God so
of course Adam who's the parent Adam and
Eve parents of of all
mankind um they the children of God
they're the Sons and Daughters of God
and we he his offspring MH all right hey
appreciate that Aon thank you so much
for your question uh you might enjoy the
book that we offer tonight about the uh
closed eyes and uh I'm sorry yeah hidden
eyes and closed ears by Joe Cruz the
number to call 800 835 6747 that is the
resource line again just ask for the
free offer it's called closed eyes and
hidden ear yeah be perfect for what you
described your study with your friend
yes absolutely we have Richard listening
from Stockton California Richard welcome
to the
program Richard you on yes uh thank you
yeah my question is um do I tithe when I
first get my check because only do I get
one check a month do I tie from that or
do I pay the Bills first then tithes I'm
having a problem with that because I'm
all I'm new to all this so I already do
the right thing well in the Bible it
talks about giving your first fruits to
God and so if you're looking for
priorities Jesus said seek first the
kingdom of God and his righteousness and
um uh you know if if we have an
obligation tithe is something God says
bring all the tithe in the storehouse
and I'll open for you the windows of
Heaven I don't think you want that to be
the last thing you do seems like he'll
bless the other 90% he promises to bless
what's left if we bring the tithe first
and so you know just because God should
have the priority I would think tithe
would go first that's right I mean the
principle of tithing is a increase so
whether that is back in Bible times it
for the most part it was Harvest so they
would take the first of the Harvest and
take 10% of the Harvest and they would
give that to the Lord's work now in our
society today that's the paycheck so we
want to take 10 10% before we pay all of
our bills ask God's blessing upon uh the
rest and give to him that which is his
MH and of course there's a blessing God
promises that he will meet the needs of
those who put their trust in him that's
right yeah he'll U he he promises to
rebuke the things that devour your
increase when we are faithful and ties
it's not just that he opens the windows
of heaven and blesses he also protects
what you've got left it's like the
children of Israel when they went
through the wilderness and they were
paying their tithe to God it says in 40
years their shoes didn't wear out and
you know he fed them every day and so
God promises to sustain you seek first
his kingdom and righteousness and he
said you won't have to worry about what
do we eat and what do we wear and uh he
feeds the I it going say he feeds the
flowers and clothes the birds but he
clothes the flowers and he feeds the
birds we have a study guy dealing with
the subject of tithing you might find
this interesting Richard is called In
God We Trust we'll be happy to send this
to you or anybody who calls and ask the
number is 800 83567 47 you can ask for
the study guide called In God We Trust
and we'll be happy to send that out our
next caller is Christopher and he's
listening from Bronx New York
Christopher welcome to the
program yes hello hi thank you for
calling and your question tonight yeah
my question is about marriage in uh
Hebrews 13 verse4 it says that marriage
is Honorable and all in the bed under
fou but wh mongers and adulter God would
judge M but in uh Luke 16:18 it talks
about those who put away their wife and
marry another committ of
adultery so my question is how how is
the first and the second marriage or the
third marriage honorable and yet God's
going to judge the Del Del OFA well if a
person does not have biblical grounds
for divorce and Me remarriage Jesus
calls it adultery and you know unless
that's something that they've repented
of of like any sin uh they will be
judged and so um you know but when Paul
says in Hebrews where assuming Paul is
the writer of Hebrews that marriage is
Honorable and the bed undefiled God his
Blessing is on marriage um God actually
performed the wedding of Adam and Eve
and the first miracle of Jesus was at a
wedding so and then the Bible ends with
a wedding in that um you've got the
wedding supper of the Lamb is how
Revelation ends a great wedding Feast so
you know God honors marriage that's why
he says that uh you know we need to
honor those covenants am I answering
what you're asking
Christopher well I'm just trying to
figure out you know if you if you could
if divorce two or three times that the
bed is still
honorable
yet I think I see what you're saying
well let me give you an example all
right if you marry or divorce without
biblical grounds and the biblical
grounds that Jesus gives in Matthew 19
Matthew 5 is adultery if if your partner
your spouse commits adultery you have
biblical grounds for divorce and then
remarriage but let's suppose you don't
have biblical grounds does that mean
that you've committed the unpardonable
sin and no it could be but not
necessarily uh you look in the Bible at
King David King David not only committed
adultery with B Sheba he not only
intruded on their their marriage with
Uriah but he had Uriah killed at the
hands of the um
ammonites well David suffered for that
he was punished he repented of his sin
but God didn't say now go divorce bath
Sheba well her husband was dead and and
uh she was pregnant at the time so um I
think they had actually had a baby at
the time so uh later it says David
comforted his
wife and just the most amazing thing is
of all David's sons and he had several
wives the one that is chosen to be the
King by God following David is Solomon
ba sheba's son between David and basba
so he obviously forgave them and then
their bed was undefiled but up until
they repented of their sin you know you
can't unscramble scrambled eggs and some
people they come to the Lord and they've
got all kinds of interesting marriage
relationships you look at the Samaritan
woman in uh John what is that chapter
four four yeah she had she said she had
five husbands she's living with one she
wasn't married to and uh Jesus revealed
to her he was the Messiah so it's you
know it's a sin to get married and
divorced and married and divorced
without biblical grounds but it doesn't
say it's the unpardonable sin and so
when a person genuinely repents and they
realize they've done something wrong you
know then you should cleave onto your
wife and uh ask God to bless your marri
marriage from that point on you know we
have a book called marriage divorce and
remarriage deals with these biblical
principles and anybody wanting to learn
more about this give us a call on our
resource line the number is
8835 6747 you can ask for the book
called marriage divorce and remarriage
if you have a Bible question the number
here to the studio is
8463 7297 again that's
8463 7297 with your Bible question we'll
be able to get it on the air this
evening we have a few lines that are
open Christopher thank you for your call
we're going to go to our next caller in
Detroit we have Raj um listening Detroit
Michigan Raj welcome to the
program thank you hi can you hear me
yeah hi okay I'm calling because I have
a question about melchisedec who's
mentioned in the beginning the middle
and the end of the Bible and here's the
question okay is it true that he is to
the angels what Jesus is to man and if
so does this mean he's an immortal with
and his order Does it include other
people uh no melkisedek was a real
person Paul in the book of Hebrews and
you find him referring to this in
Hebrews 5 he refers to melkisedek as a
type of Christ now there were many Old
Testament characters that are real
people that were types there's things in
their lives that were Echoes of Jesus
Joseph who was sold by his brothers and
yet he forgave them um and he was sold
for the price of a slave he he's like a
type of Christ David as he you know
weeps on the Mount of Olives over
Jerusalem like Jesus wept over Jerusalem
he's a type of Christ and Moses when he
you know even Moses said the Lord your
God will raise up a prophet like me
speaking of Jesus so there were a number
of types of Christ in the Old Testament
melkisedek is one of them when it says
he's without beginning of days or end
Paul is simply referring to the fact
that melkisedek appears in the Book of
Genesis with no
genealogy it doesn't tell who his
ancestors are what tribe he's from where
he comes from or what happened to him
and his people he appears and disappears
historically but doesn't mean he was an
angel or the Holy Spirit I've heard a
lot of theories he was a real person
part of the reason we know that is
Abraham gives him tithe and tithe wasn't
just money they gave him wheat and stuff
and melkisedek brings out Wine and Food
for Abraham and his army they have a
very real tangible
relationship you know the whole point of
this mchis priesthood that Paul speaks
of in Hebrews chapter 5 and 6 he says
Abraham gave a tith to melchisedek and
through Abraham's sin it's the Levites
came and they were the ones that
received a tith from the children of
Israel but here he illustrating that
melkisedek was even greater than the
levitical priesthood and that he stands
as a type of Christ It also says that he
was a king so he was both a priest and a
king and of course we know Jesus he also
has a role as priest he is ministering
for us in his heavly Sanctuary but he's
also the king of kings and Lord of lords
yeah and melkisedek means king of
righteousness and Jesus is our righteous
King one more thing maybe two more
things melkisedek was a king of Salem
later known as
Jerusalem and uh Jesus is the king of
the New Jerusalem and I think the last
thing I was going to say is melkisedek
brought forth Bread and Wine to Abraham
Jesus gave Bread and Wine at the New
Covenant so he's a he's a very powerful
type of Christ in the Old Testament but
he was a real
person some people think now this is
pure speculation but I've read that I
don't know if it was Josephus or
somebody in ancient history said that
melkisedek they thought was uh Shem the
descendant of Noah who was still alive
during the time of Abraham that he had
come out from Mesopotamia because he had
heard Abraham still worship the true God
that's a little bit fanciful but it's
fun to think about anyway hope that
helps a little bit Raj yeah good
question all right again if you have a
related question the number to call is
800- 463 7297 with your Bible question
that's 800
46372 97 we have Peter who's listening
from um Florida Peter welcome to the
program hello hi you're on the air Peter
yes so my question is um is getting
saved only way to get to heaven and also
how do you get saved and how do you know
that you are saved when you get saved
all right stay the first part of your
question again um is getting saved the
only way to get to
heaven well certainly if you're lost you
don't get there so the alternative would
be saved now will there be people in
heaven that maybe had not heard about
Jesus and I would say yes you know
Christ said that there'll be others that
come from the East and the west and sit
down in the Kingdom with Abraham Isaac
and Jacob U there'll be people in from
Old Testament times that maybe Jesus
wasn't born yet obviously they'll be
there or they didn't understand the
mission of the Messiah
there may be people like you know God
says that he saved naam and Jesus talks
about this when he begins his ministry
in Nazareth they'll be people like Nam
and the leper and the Canaanite woman
that Elijah stayed with that are not
Jews that God spoke to and worked to and
ministered to through angels and they
lived in they followed up on the light
that they had but basically they are
being saved by the grace of God and by
walking in the light that God has given
them so everyone saved everyone in
Heaven is saved by Jesus nobody gets to
heaven without Christ there'll be some
people there that are saved by faith in
God but maybe they didn't understand all
the details of Christ in his ministry
now part of your question was well how
does a person get saved I think it all
begins by first of all recognizing your
need until we realize that we need a
savior we won't really be looking for
Christ and Christ is the savior he's
willing to um save and the way he does
so is through his sacrifice on Calvary
he takes our place he dies for our sins
and then more than that he gives us of
his spirit and begins to work within our
hearts and lives as we learn to trust in
him and we grow spiritually uh sometimes
the theological term that be used
justification that represents Christ's
atoning sacrifice for our sins and
sanctification is the working of the
Holy Spirit within us and that
culminates in what we call glorification
that's when Jesus comes again and the
Earth is finally recreated there's no
more pain no more sorrow no more sin but
he makes all things new that's Heaven
that's Heaven yep you know we do have a
book dealing with this very important
subject how do we get saved how do we
get to heaven it's called three steps to
Heaven it just breaks it down real clear
three things we need to do to come into
that saving relationship with Jesus
we'll be happy to send this to you Peter
or anybody who calls and asks the number
again is 800 835
6747 that is the resource line and you
can ask for the book called three steps
to Heaven that's 800 835 6747 ask for
the book three steps to Heaven we'll be
happy to send it to
you our next caller then is Wesley
listening from also Florida Wesley
welcome to the
program yes hello I have a question um I
have a children and they want to buy um
toy toy guns what does Bible says about
uh buying weapons toys uh for children
and um they are boys and they really
like to have their guns what do you say
Pastor well first I'd say It's Perfectly
Normal as a father of several boys uh I
I I don't know I think they first begin
pretending they're shooting things
before they're
born uh they just sort of are launched
that way so you know God makes boys with
a little bit of uh aggression and uh
they you know they see it it's in the
world around us it's in all the
entertainment so just you it's to be
expected when I was a kid now it's very
Politically Incorrect but it was Cowboys
and Indians and you know everybody had
the cap six shooters and so but now
you're asking does the bible address
that well you know the Bible doesn't say
um you don't buy your kids a toy gun um
certainly in the time of the Old
Testament you know from the time David
was taking care of his father's sheep he
had a sling that was the closest thing
to project a missile back then and he
probably was playing with one of those
things from an early age as a Christian
you you don't want to be talking about
taking other life and so if a person's
thinking about I want a gun so I can
shoot people uh there's something wrong
with that Philosophy for Christians but
you know try and get kids to not throw
rocks or boys in particular and maybe
even girls um that's sort of wired you
know if I I don't recommend you go out
and buy your kids guns you know Jesus
said he that lives by the sword dies by
the
sword if they understand that a gun can
be a tool and the reason I say this is
when we grew up our older boys we lived
on a ranch and they actually used the
guns as uh protection we had bears and
coyotes and all kinds of animals up
there mountain lions but um you we'd
always teach them you got to respect
life Hey Wesley I hope that helps answer
your question don't mean to cut you off
but we're at the Hard break at our
halftime we are not going away friends
we're going to take a brief break if you
have a Bible question still have lines
open 800 God says we're going to be back
talking to you with more questions in
just a couple of minutes
[Music]
Bible answers live returning just a
moment if you're looking for bible-based
materials for further study sign up for
amazing fax's free correspondence Bible
study course or check out our sale
catalog featuring hundreds of inspiring
books and tapes to order call our
resource line at 800 835
6747 that's 800 83567
47 amazing facts is a faith-based
listener supported Ministry operating
exclusively through the generosity of
your prayers and financial gifts we
would love to hear from you write to us
at PO Box 909 Roseville California
95678 or online at amazingfacts.org
you're listening to Bible answers live
with Pastor Doug Bachelor if you have a
Bible related question call us to
receive clear honest answers directly
from scripture we have a few lines open
so please give us a call the phone
number to the studio is 800 God says
that's 800 463
7297 if you've enjoyed Bible answers
live you'll love Pastor Doug's Book of
Bible answers straight from the
broadcast the very best questions and
answers have been compiled as an awesome
resource for Bible study and personal
evangelism each answer has been expanded
with more Bible verses and insightful
comment comary the book of Bible answers
can be yours today for just $12 call now
35674 and request offer 257 that's 1800
6747 we're back listening friends this
is Bible answers live and as you may
gather from the title it's your
opportunity to call in with a Bible
question we're live and the number 800
God says that's 8004
63729 it's a free phone call and we
focus our attention not on finance or
romance but on the word of God Bible
questions 800- 463 7297 my name is Doug
Bachelor my name is Jean Ross and again
friends if you have a Bible related
question the phone line again to the
studio in case you missed it the first
time it's
7297 our next call is Larry it's
listening from North Carolina Larry
walking to the
program hello hi Larry you're on I'm
calling about the genes chap 29 okay
verses 1- 12 well I may not that's the
story where Jacob meets Rachel I may not
be able to read all that do do you have
a specific question a general question
about have y'all ever thought about
these verses uh as if they were prophecy
is there any prophecy hidden
here well you know I don't know that I
have I would not be a bit surprised if
there's not some allegories in here
about when he sees U you know Rachel
coming and he's caring for uh Jacob is
able to move the stone he does it
single-handedly from the well someone
once said that she must have been pretty
because he kissed her and wept but um I
guess it does say she's pretty it's
interesting David's caring for his
father's sheep Rachel's caring for her
father's sheep and Moses is caring for
the Sheep of his father-in-law and Jesus
he said I'm the Good Shepherd and he's
caring for his father sheep so there's
some allegories here but that's
different than a prophecy why did you
think you might have seen something
prophetic in these verses did I think
you know what we may have got cut off
from that call I hopefully you're maybe
you can call back and and let us know
but u i I've not thought of these verses
about where Jacob first meets and um
gets to know Rachel as a prophecy but
there may be allegories in there which
is a little different there's some types
of Christ in the story and sorry we we
lost you we don't know if it was
technical or what with that we're going
to have to go to another call Pastor
Ross we have Fred listening from um
Stanford Connecticut Fred welcome to the
program uh yes good evening p a question
uh the number 24 does that represent the
priesthood all right Pastor Ross you're
a resident a revelation scholar you want
to you were just talking about this last
week we were yeah we were talking about
this you're probably referring to 24 in
Revelation where it talks about the 24
alas in Revelation chapter 4 yes yeah
there's two main lines of thought as to
who they are the one is that they the um
representatives of the unfallen worlds
you have a group referred to in the Book
of Job And there it's referred to as the
sons of God and um they sort of
fulfilling the role that Adam would have
filled had he not Fallen to the devil's
Temptation you remembering the story
Satan shows up and God says where did
you come from and he says all walking up
and down on the earth so um some believe
that the 24 Elders would then represent
these um unfallen worlds that you read
about in Hebrews chapter 1 another
thought is that the 24 Elders were those
who were resurrected at the time of
Christ's Resurrection the Bible refers
to them a group we don't know how many
but it talks about the graves being open
and many of those who slept AR Rose and
they appeared in Jerusalem and then the
Bible doesn't say anything else about
them um then Paul refers to when Christ
ascended on high he led captivity
captive and gave gifts unto men and some
see it as those who were resurrected
ascended with Jesus as first fruits and
uh they could possibly be the 24 Elders
as well so it's a fascinating study I I
kind of like the leaning towards it
being the representatives of the
unfallen world you know it's also
interesting in the Old Testament if you
look in 1 Chronicles 27 it talks about
this group of 24 groups of 24,000 and so
there were 24 captains and it names them
benah was one of them who ended up
becoming Solomon's General but um so you
got these 24 captains of
24,000 and um that is so 24 is a common
number 12 and divisions of 12 are often
seen in the Old Testament as numbers for
leadership like the 12 apostles some
argue there were 12 judges 12 princes of
Moses and uh 12 Apostles in the New
Testament so having 24 Elders in the uh
Book of Revelation would talk about some
kind of leadership in God's Cosmos hey
thank you very much we appreciate that
Fred hope it helps a little bit and we
do have a book that talks about the
144,000 we'll send you a free copy and
it says a little more in there about the
24 Elders the number to call is 8835
6747 it's called Uh the 144,000 who are
they we'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls and asks again 800 835
6747 and if you have a Bible question
the phone line here is
8463 7297 our next caller is Roy and
he's listening from New Jersey Roy
welcome to the program thank you for
taking my call yeah thanks for calling
um my question is in in Rel relationship
to um Genesis 1:27 so God created man in
his own image in the image of God he
created him male and female uhuh um in
reading the Bible I carry the question
over to um Adam and Eve and Cain and
Abel and after Cain had killed his
brother he was talking there in the
verse it says I fear lest any man find
me they would kill me so God put a seal
on his forehead Mark and if there were
no other men on Earth why would he have
not said there are no other people on
Earth you are the only one and from
there the very next verse it says he
went to the city of Nod and there he
took him a wife so there was obviously a
city there was obviously other people
living and that my perception of it is
that um Adam and Eve were created as a
special race unto God which is what the
what Genesis tells us what say you well
I'd respectfully disagree I I think that
when Cain said um you know my curse is
too big for me to bear that men Finding
Me will kill me first of all God had
told Adam and Eve to go forth be
fruitful multiply they lived hundreds of
years according to the Bible and it
tells you in Genesis 5 that they had
many sons and daughters besides Cain and
Abel and Seth there's many unnamed they
usually just named the firstborn that
were the uh uh the ones that trace the
genealogy Cain knew there'd be many it
says Cain went and he actually created a
city it says in another place and so he
went to Moses is writing about this he
said he went to the place that is now
known as the area of Nod so Moses is
saying for reference of people who are
reading years later that um this is the
region that Cain went to I think he went
East of Eden and he founded a city there
and so uh uh there were no people yet
Kain knew that as the world became
populated that he would be a Marked Man
because God had said be fruitful
multiply to Adam and Eve and you know
the plan was to fill the Earth and there
were probably by the time the flood came
who knows so you extrapolate how many
people there could have been there could
have been Millions so does that make
sense Roy where did the wife come from
well Cain married one of his sisters it
says Adam and Eve had sons and daughters
and if you read Abraham married his
sister Sarah was a half sister of
Abraham and Isaac married his first
cousin as did Jacob so it wasn't that
odd back think about it Adam and Eve did
they have the same
parents so technically Adam married his
sister I know it's kind of a weird
thought for us today technically he
married his
twin well that's even weirder isn't it
you know it's not until the time of
Moses where we have a a clear um command
by God not to marry a brother or a
sister and um it seems that before the
flood you know the health people live so
long and vitality and so on it seemed to
be okay at least it was there were no
genetic problems they weren't back then
yeah all right so hope that helps a
little Roy and appreciate that I don't
know that we've got anything written in
a book about that but uh that's the
answer that we give appreciate your call
you know maybe there is a book that came
to mind we have the book called who are
the sons of God oh and I think that
might deal with this as well and we'll
be happy to send it to you Roy or
anybody wanting to learn more about this
aliens Angels or adopted who are the
sons of God that's right the number to
call is 800 83567 47 that is the
resource line you can ask for the book
called who are the sons of God aliens
Angels or adopted Angels or adopted
that's right our next call is otus
listening from Orlando Florida otus
Welcome to the program hello hi Otis
you're on the air yes okay my question
is if someone
uh get divorced for a reason that's not
sanctioned by the Bible and they remarry
or they commit adultery and if they stay
married to that person are they in a
continuing state of adultery well first
of all you just you sort of answered
your own question with the first
question if they get divorced and
remarried without the support of the
Bible are they committing adultery well
Jesus said that those that divorce and
remarry saving for the cause of
fornication meaning short of um someone
violating the marriage value says they
commit adultery and they're causing the
person they marry to commit adultery now
the question is is adultery the
unpardonable sin and once you are
married to that person you can't always
just say well I I'm I'm not supposed to
be married or I shouldn't have married
you and so now I'm going to get divorced
then you compound your problem because
you've made another Covenant with a new
person and uh you know you got to keep
that Covenant but at some point you're
going to have to come to terms if a
person gets married and divorced and
remarried without biblical grounds well
they broken a covenant and um uh they
committed adultery biblically the
question is what do they do now and so
people wonder well you know what do I do
do I now I let's I get divorced and
remarried without biblical grounds the
Bible says you shouldn't then divorce
your wife and go back to your original
wife that would be even worse it's
almost turns into like Sanctified wife
swapping and so um uh you know you need
to stick with the person you're with and
keep your Covenant repent of your sin
and move
on but if you stay with that same person
AR you still living in
adultery well you
know what you've made a covenant you
committed adultery if you've divorced
the other person now if you're in an
affair you need to cut that off and go
back to your
spouse but if you've divorced your
spouse and you remarry and sometimes in
there's children involved you you've
made a promise to the second person you
did commit adultery you started
completely Ely on the wrong foot but if
you've come to your senses you repented
you want to do God's will you need to
repent and say from here on I'm going to
follow God and um you know there's
consequences that we usually experience
in this life for multiple divorces and
remarriages especially without biblical
grounds you know the book um marriage
divorce and remarriage I think you'll
find this interesting uh it covers a lot
of these subjects and we'll be happy to
send that to you so anybody who call
asks just give us a call on the Source
number it's 8835 6747 ask for the book
called marriage divorce and remarriage
again that number is 8835
6747 and if you have a Bible question
the number here to the studio is
8463 7297 to get your Bible question on
the air our next call is Tim listening
from Toronto Canada Tim welcome to the
program thank you thank you um I just I
had a question um addressed to me and I
tried to answer like I guess the best of
my ability um and the way it went was
like this uh if in the Bible God is
telling us in the end times it's going
to get really evil just like in the
times of Noah so it will be um like near
the end um why should we continue uh I
guess like to fight and pray or like you
know how the oops wait let's see if we
can get you back sorry Tim we lost you
there for a minute yes so why should we
fight and pray for people in leadership
is that what you're asking yes yes if
it's G to get evil no matter what that's
the question was asked me yeah well you
know Paul tells us in the New Testament
that we should pray for those that have
authority over us pray for those that
are in leadership and uh you know it's
not always easy and sometimes we see
people that are in those positions of
leadership uh doing
some pretty shameful things but um you
know God's word is pretty clear that uh
we ought to we ought to pray for them
that God will give them wisdom um there
are a few people in high places you got
examples in the Bible of a few
administrators that did the right thing
you got Cyrus the Persian king and
you've got uh David and Solomon and and
there were some others uh and you need
to pray for them I mean even David when
Nebuchadnezzar did a lot of terrible
things uh I should say Daniel Prayed for
him and so and you know what Daniel pray
prayed and this is the way to approach
it Daniel Prayed that Nebuchadnezzar
would break off his sins by
righteousness that it might be a
lengthening of his Tranquility he didn't
say everything was going to go right but
he said you might lengthen the period of
Tranquility or peace I think we're
praying that there'll be peaceful
opportunity for us to preach the gospel
a little longer we know how the story is
going to end there's going to be a great
time of trouble and all kinds of
commotion but for the meantime we ought
to pray that U God's not willing that
people perish he wants the gospel to go
out and pray for people in leadership
they can make the best decisions and boy
do we need to pray now amen things are
things are aess in uh uh in in
leadership of the world and we need to
pray I better not comment it's bad
enough I'm talking about religion I
better not get into
politics hey appreciate your call Tim I
don't know if that helps any no it does
it helps a lot all right he thanks so
much I was looking for that verse Pastor
Ross where it says you know you're
supposed to pray for the government
leaders of the government doesn't bear
The Sword in vain and I I Had a Brain
cramp can't find it but I know it's in
there in uh Romans chapter 13 thank you
very much several verses that talk about
that we have David who's listening from
um Stockton California David welcome to
the program hello hi David you're on the
air oh okay I'm from Vancouver BC
actually I was driving to the listen to
you guys program my question is pretty
simple when the Adam and Eve uh the God
created them they put them in the garden
and uh uh and they blessed uh the God
blessed them uh to multiply whatever
after that but before they commit a sin
do they have any sons and daughters or
anything that if they were and because
they they wouldn't be in a sin and where
where would they be yeah I don't think
Adam and Eve had any children before
their sin because for one thing God says
that part of the penalty or the curse of
sin is that in pain a woman would
conceive and bring forth children and
Adam had his punishment um God had told
Adam and Eve to be fruitful and multiply
but they evidently hadn't done any
multiplying yet because even after they
sinned he's still repeating the command
to be fruitful and multiply and so I
don't think they'd had any children I
think that shortly after creation I
don't think they enjoyed Paradise for
very long before the devil tempted them
and they it was a short honeymoon they
tripped up yeah I appreciate that good
question God bless David all right thank
you for your call and uh our next call
is uh banina listening from Queens New
York Bono welcome to the program hello
yes you have a question yes I wonder if
a pastor could help me with I'm finding
out the expression in Hebrew of the word
joyful noise Make a Joyful Noise unto
the Lord yes uh just these two words I
would like to know the the the Hebrew
version of them all right well I'll look
it up Joyful Noise you know if you could
help me to find the uh the Hebrew the
Hebrew word for it yeah um let me see
here Pastor Ross I don't know if you've
got it yet uh we have one in Psalms 98:4
where it says Make a Joyful Noise unto
the Lord all the Earth make a loud noise
and rejoice with singing In Praise um
that's the one you're wondering
about you want to know what the Hebrew
means huh do would you have would you
have the words in Hebrew yeah we do I'm
just it up right here shout joyfully to
the Lord uh it means to shout joyfully
and um let me see here Joyful
Noise Hebrew the Hebrew expression of
Joyful
Noise yeah let me see you know literally
the I'm looking it up here in the Hebrew
it means the literal meaning is
expressing or something causing a show
of
Joy it the word actually
yeah the word actually is
Haru and it means how you well when
you're using Hebrew and you're
converting it to English what you have
to do is get the best English word and
it's got h a r i you but you need to
know what the punctuation is yeah you
got to know what the punctuation is
around that and um I've even got a
program here that'll say it but I I'm
not GNA you know be delving into that so
why do you ask that question hope why do
you want to know that I well you you
know uh Christians are C curious you
know behind curiosity I want to know the
Hebrew the Hebrew expression of the word
Joyful Noise well it's it's actually one
word that translates shout joyfully they
had a happy shout and it was it's the
word um like I said it says Haru in uh
in my Hebrew translation here and um
that's that's the word I don't speak
Hebrew not very much anyway hey I hope
that helps a little bit benah and next
call is Scott listening from Minnesota
Scott welcome to the
program Scott you're on the
air good evening
evening my question is the scriptures
indicate to me that we all are given a
choice to either SE accept Jesus Christ
as Savior or reject him and then after
this life we never have that opportunity
again we're fixed that's right but
there's Mill there's millions of little
babies being aborted that don't have a
choice and there's also people you know
the Muslims or whatever oh I shouldn't
have said that but in this lifetime they
don't get to receive the Gospel when do
they get their choice you mean you
talking about like aborted babies if are
there's probably number of other
scenarios of little children that maybe
die in infancy that uh don't get that
opportunity is that what you're asking
correct yes I agree yeah there's
different circumstances where people
don't get the choice to make after the
age of accountability to make a choice
to receive Christ or reject when do they
get their choice let me read you a
difficult verse in the Book of Job it
says in verse chapter 10: 19 job says I
would have been as though I had not been
I would have been carried from the womb
to the gra grave job is describing here
a miscarried child and you know they
didn't probably have the problem with
abortion back then that we have today
and he says you know a baby that has
never seen the light of day that goes
from the womb to the Grave a very sad
picture and job says as though they had
not been now at the very least you would
understand that God doesn't take
children who die before the age of
accountability and they don't suffer the
punishment of the wicked because they if
they're not accountable that means
they're innocent of that they may be
born with the human Fallen nature but
they've not committed any known sin they
don't they've not had an opportunity to
accept the gospel some may be as though
they had not been this is a struggle
it's a difficult question because if you
do the math and you think about all of
the children that die in
infancy that in the resurrection for
every adult that accepts the Lord you
would have a thousand babies because
it's says straight As the gate and
narrow as the way that leads to life so
you know you you've got a few
comparatively few people that accept
Jesus that are in the kingdom and if
every baby conceived is in
heaven wow we're going to have a nursery
up there it's I I know that I don't want
to be sarcastic because it's a difficult
question oh on the you know the same
line though we do have the promise in
God's word that um parents who have
suffered the loss of a child a baby uh
they can they can still have comfort and
hope in the promise that there is
resurrection and um mothers get to hold
the babies that were taken from them and
here's a verse you remember the story at
the time of Christ's birth when Herod
sent out his soldiers to kill all the
baby boys to and under in Bethlehem um
there is actually a quote in Matthew
from Jeremiah Jeremiah
31:16 and the quote is thus sayith the
Lord refrain your your voice from
weeping and your eyes from tears for
your work shall be rewarded sayith the
Lord and they shall come back from the
land of the enemy now that verse is
quoted with reference to the destruction
of the baby boys and specifically words
of comfort to the mother or to the
parents saying your child will come back
meaning the land of the Enemy being that
of death so there is the promise of the
Resurrection for those who have not
reached the age of accountability but is
every child that's ever been conceived
going to be born or you know that
that'll be a decision I guess God will
have to make but one more verse on what
Pastor Ross was saying if you look in 1
Corinthians 7:14 it says the unbelieving
husband is Sanctified by the wife and
the unbelieving wife is Sanctified by
the husband otherwise your children
would be unclean but now they're holy in
other words through the faith and the
prayers of the believing husband or wife
if they're in a mixed marriage the
children are there's a sanctifying
effect somehow that means there is some
difference that happens for the children
of Believers but I don't believe as some
Christians teach that unless a baby's
baptized that they're all going to go to
hell I I think that's an outrageous
belief uh but there are promises that
the children of believing parents if
they die before the age of
accountability are in heaven now the
bigger question you're asking is why do
they get a chance how do how come they
don't get a chance well there's a lot of
people in the world that haven't heard
the gospel children and adults and
that's why the Lord wants us to reach as
many as we can it's sad that the devil
has claimed this territory and and he's
held so many captive
we have time for one more or are we
short I'm just looking we probably have
time well it's going to be a little
tight past the deck we do want to let
folks know about an event that's coming
up uh actually in March March the 21st
through the 26th in Charlotte North
Carolina that's right just a little more
than a month we're going to be in the
city of Charlotte we're uplinking a
brand new series that'll start on the
21st and it's called the last day of
Prophecy discover the rest of the story
and this will be broadcast
live on television it'll be on 3abn
Amazing Facts hope Channel Roku and we
want to encourage you just go to the
website last day ofrc se.com and find
out how to sign up and register your
site or your church it's going to be a
great event so listening friends if we
did not get to your question tonight God
willing give us another chance in the
future and um please keep in mind
amazing facts is entirely supported by
people like you who are calling in
questions and listening to answers and
we just pray the Holy Spirit will move
on your heart to say hey I learned
something tonight I want to keep a
program like this on the air be one of
our friends go to the website click
contact and you can make a donation
right there God bless you friends and
Lord willing we'll be studying his word
together
again this has been a pre-recorded
broadcast of Bible answers live a
production of amazing facts Ministries
if you would like to order the materials
mentioned on this broadcast call 800 835
6747 from 8:00 a.m. to midnight Eastern
Standard Time That's 800 835
6747 if you've missed an episode of
Bible answers live you can find it on
our website amazingfacts.org you'll also
find our online sale catalog of books
tapes and other materials as well as
numerous free resources on nearly every
Bible topic putting the answers to your
Bible questions right at your fingertips
if you've been blessed by this program
let us know write to us at PO Box 909
Roseville California
9995678 be sure to tell others about the
program and join us again next time for
more Bible answers live with Pastor Doug
Bachelor I grew up in a churchgoing
family I mean we were at every meeting I
sang in four of the choirs there I
directed three very involved very active
it almost seemed like busy work
sometimes you know I I went to Sunday
school I I knew about God I knew about
Jesus but I didn't have a personal
relationship with Jesus
Christ my senior year in high school I
got the news that my father had been
murdered I played it off well no one
really saw that I was struggling with it
it just really felt like there was a
hole that needed to be filled and I
tried to fill it with drugs with alcohol
with partying after college I just
stopped going to church all
[Music]
together one day on a Sunday cuz I
didn't feel like going to church with my
mom I thought you know I should get a
little bit of work she had the satellite
system hooked up and I'm flipping
through channels and then the logo pops
across amazing facts presents I've
listened to a lot of different ministers
but he was this was the first time that
he's actually saying something where I
had to grab my Bible and actually pick
it up and I've never heard this before
let me let me look through and find this
I went through all the storical I went
through all the study guyses and I just
couldn't get enough and then the Sabbath
came up and he's going through the
appeal and I'm just going Lord I hear
you I have to go to church so I show up
it was funny I didn't feel like I was
going to be judged anything judgmental
anything and I walked in the door and I
just felt at
home but there's still a
problem I'm still partying I was still
going out to the bars at this time I was
selling cocaine to pay my
rent 16 days later I find myself in a
life or death situation I had just came
back from the liquor store and I grabbed
a bottle of
vodka and there I am high off cocaine
with my Bible in hand trying to do a
Bible
study and I heard an audible voice just
look at
yourself and I did and I was
like what am I
doing and I got on my knees I said Lord
if you do not take this away from me now
I'm going going to kill
myself I was going to continue this
lifestyle and I was going to end up
overdosing having a heart attack
whatever it was you have to take this
away all of
it and that day he lifted all of it away
from me it was all gone when God does
something in your life he does it
complete
[Music]
for more than 45 years the ministry of
amazing facts has been helping people
from all walks of life understand their
Bibles better than ever before through
television radio and the internet we
impact countless lives each day around
the world by sharing Bible truth that
transforms lives forever if you've been
blessed by our programs will you help
share in this work with a tax deductible
gift today when you support amazing
facts you give Lasting Hope and make it
possible for others to hear the good
news of Jesus Christ and experience his
eternal love to give a gift call 1 1800
7171 once again that's 1 1800 891 7171
or go to donate. amazingfacts.org
[Music]